did you know that the obano civilization
in the Amazon flourished due to their
Advanced agricultural techniques they
created raised fields and water
reservoirs to improve crop production in
the rich Amazonian soil they also built
a complex water system consisting of
canals and storage ponds which helped in
irrigation and fishing their remains
discovered in areas like Bolivia and
Brazil include large architectural
structures used in ceremonial rituals
featuring platforms and large Stone
circles the oboi were in harmony with
nature cleverly using local plants and
animals in their daily crafts and
religious rituals which aspect of the
obano civilization fascinates you the
most share your thoughts in the comments